citizens with us in Texas hi Susan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you um I have a question for you
that has a lot of components but we just
moved to Texas six months ago and while
our house recently became debt-free Oh
No
except for our mortgage so but now my
husband wants to take a job in another
city in Texas and my question is I just
you just moved and took a job why is he
changing again I think he is looking for
the perfect job that will make him happy
since he retired from the military so I
spent 27 years jumping through a hundred
hoops to move places so that he could be
happy in his job now we're here I
actually met you when I came to business
boutique in October and have moved my
business here and have really put a lot
into it to build it up from nothing I
don't know what does he do because of
moving he is a helicopter pilot okay and
and he would like to leave and go
somewhere else and do what manage a
helicopter program what city are you in
now in Texas San Antonio ok I'm with you
it's time for him to quit running around
in circles
time to stop he's looking for love in
all the wrong places and he's not going
to find the perfect job he's not going
to find the perfect thing he's gonna
have to create that wherever he is and
you're done moving you told me that he's
heard that from you and you've been
supportive of him and it's time now for
him to calm his butt down sit there and
fly helicopters and if he wants to move
into managing helicopter a helicopter
operation then develop that start a
business go to work for somebody and set
the goal of being in management
being a pilot all of that's fine you can
do every bit of that in San Antonio
Texas well Dave he's going I mean he's
he's going he they're just working out
the details of his offer so the question
for me is whether it's better for him to
rent and something up there or whether
we buy him something up there oh so
you're going to separate he's unwilling
to not go for you and you're unwilling
to go with him wow this is - he's not
unwilling to not go I know I know and
I'm trying to but I can't
I do have responsible for making him
happy in his job yeah you have for 20
years yeah for 20 years you're being
very kind and then we've been married
for 36 okay then for 36 years he drug
you around all over the world as a
military wife which is fine and you
didn't gripe about it till now but now
you said I'm not moving anymore and he
goes I'm moving again anyway come on
dude this is the third time since he's
retired that we've done this this is
this is a this is not a career problem
this is a contentment problem and he
keeps looking for a magic pill and there
are no magic pills and that's that he's
not gonna find it there either Sam yeah
and you're not gonna double your
household expenses because he's giving
now you're gonna try to operate two
households and yet one more effort for
him I just I think it's bad career
advice I think he needs to get a hold of
Ken Coleman let me send you a copy the
book the proximity principle and for him
but what you're describing is looking
for love in all the wrong places looking
for contentment and fulfillment and a
play it's never gonna be there it's a
bully in the schoolyard steps back and
draws the line the senses step over step
over the line and steps back draws
another line and that's what happiness
does when you pursue it like this